uh years later Mike Tyson apologized to
you what what what's meaningful to you
about that how does that fit the story I
want to be the great gracious guy right
now say oh I'm so hum human that that
you know a man's manad enough to say
sorry that's it uh we're good I want to
be really that that's that's that's the
that's the best presentation of Teddy
Atlas I could put out there he's a good
guy he forgives he he's a good guy he's
a he's a he's a standup guy and he's a
good guy I'm not
sure if he truly did it for himself that
he really did
it because he felt
that it was
true but but if he's persuaded by other
things he was in the middle I know I'm
taking it too deep I know but what am I
going to do he was in the middle of 12
steps with the you know getting out of
drugs alcohol 12 steps which is a
commemorable thing really it is and and
he's taking the steps and part of the
steps was to admit all to apologize to
all people you offended in
life
okay
but are you doing it for the 12 steps or
you doing it because you
really
truly have come to terms with
believing what you did was that hurtful
to me and that it matters to you that it
was that hurtful to me and that you were
wrong in doing it did you do it for I
know that's deep I know that I'm a
freaking IDI I'm a you're you're a Teddy
freaking you're you're you should be
better than that he's better than you
yeah maybe he is better than me maybe he
is really seriously maybe he is
and and I took it he put his hand I took
it I we hugged he said I love you I I I
yeah
yeah I but I want to
believe but what did CZ tell me no
matter what a man says it's what he does
in the end that he intended to do all
along so to this day
today was it really genuine or was it
reflexive of that moment for him to get
what he needed to you know for that step
or was it
truly for what I needed to to really
that he really
cared that what he did to me caused me
to do what I did because I did something
that was pretty damn bad to him too is
he able
to deal with that and put that where it
has to be put is he able to put that or
or is it just he did something he had to
do and maybe he's sorry he did it I know
him look I appreciate that
he I would have rather been in a private
place yeah so for people don't know you
were in the middle of commentating a
fight and he walked up from behind you
and he said he was sorry he shook your
hand gave you a hug I didn't know he
said I love you yeah he's emotional I
get emotional a little bit too but but
he he's emotional and he can be and he
can be I can see why people have a
Fascination in a love affair with him
right now because he
was because you know he
was he was the meteor the meteor that
went across the sky that is if they
didn't see it their parents told them
about it there was a media that came
across the sky one day and and and the
media is walking around in the room now
and that's the meteorite and then and it
actually landed here and and that's it
right there and and and now he's come a
long way and now he's you know he's more
human and and he he's lovable you know
and and compassionate and he cries and
and I get the fascin I get the love
affair I get it because we're inherently
we're people that want to forgive we're
people that we want to be good we and
part of being good is to forgive people
and to to show compassion to people and
so and when somebody
been
damaged uh to acknowledge they've been
damaged to acknowledge that you know
they've been damaged and you care about
them being damaged and how do you show
care through admiration you know in in
some ways almost through adol and he's
getting adol from people like you know
uh which is to an incredible level and
it's because it's a phenomena but but I
get it I understand it and um
I don't know if he gets it I don't know
if underneath all of this he's a complex
guy he's a sensitive guy I don't know
and I am too yeah and one complex guy
talking about another complex guy I
don't know if Underneath It All where
he's really truly at as far as that day
that he said that to me is there part of
you that's sorry to Mike for I'm not
sorry pulling the gun on him yeah and
that's listen that's fair
I know dimensions of human nature too
well to not know that he still has to
have certain because I have those strong
feelings what it's not fair for him to
have them damn right it's
fair now now he could look at it if if
he was to be held to his word that night
that he just acknowledges that what
happened he deserved because of what he
you know the position he put me in and
he put himself in what he did and I
wouldn't change nothing you know still
you're you don't regret pulling the gun
on him I regret that I had to yeah yeah
I regret very much that that I had to
that I regret very much I'm he crossed
the line I hated him for putting me in
that
position that that you know how dare he
think that that somebody's feelings are
that
trivial that the way I feel about myself
and the way the girl would feel about
herself that was 11 years old at the
time how she would feel about herself
how how dare that he think it's that
trivial that you
know that I shouldn't be ready to
freaking to both die and kill for that
yeah why didn't
custom see it in a deeper way and talk
through it he did the word came back to
me but of course what does it
mean but the word came back to me that
said you were right but if he took the
side of Teddy he would destroy a
potentially a great a great fighter why
why do you think that okay if you were
to try to understand the point he was
making why why is that true is isn't the
part of greatness that you said is
building the character of knowing what
is right what you know cuz was afraid to
to go there where he used to not be
afraid because it's kind of like you're
never afraid of going up and I I get it
you know when I train to fight an hour
if I come out of retirement I train to
fight an hour I feel in Camp like I'm I
feel like I'm on death row every day
that that if every day I I try to
retrace my memory and say did I feel
this way when I was younger I I don't
remember feeling this way I feel every
day a dreadful feeling that if I don't
get this right I I I betrayed everything
I betrayed the fighters trust I betrayed
uh what I'm supposed to be and then one
day I tried to figure it out why do I
feel this way it's so intense I was in
Camp for two months training a guy for
the world title a couple few years ago
um fighting the hardest puncher in the
world at the time and um adona Stevenson
and the fighter was Ukrainian and I was
you know brought in to train him for
that fight and he trusted me and changed
his whole style trusted me oh my God I
went to bed every night like praying um
dread waking up dread my stomach down to
here every saying what what if I fail
him what what what if everything that I
told him was going to happen don't
happen what if I fail him what what if
he trusted me and I I betrayed that
trust and the thing was the with cus was
you know he used to be stronger than
that and then I I tried to figure out
why I got this way and why it was so
Dreadful to me and why I felt like I was
on death row every day trading a fighter
like did I do enough did I do right well
well will we accomplish what we well we
accomplish what I promised him we would
accomplish would I keep my word and and
then I started thinking what how did I
become this week how did I freaking
become I was a pretty strong freaking
guy how did I become this week and then
finally I think I figured it out you
know why because I was always working to
get up but once I finally got up now I
was looking down and I found hit me I
said I didn't want to lose I said there
was nothing to lose on my way up mhm now
all of a sudden there's something to
lose when you're up there and you're
looking down and that's where he was and
and that's where cuz was cuz cuz was at
the end of his rope he he was he
accomplished the two World Champs all
the stuff right everything he and and
and he did it right now all of a sudden
it wasn't about moving forward it was
about not falling
down holy cow I was like I got it cus I
got it I got it you didn't want to fall
down oh my God you didn't want fall and
he this was his last
chance you don't give up on life this
was his last chance to live
forever to to make everything he did
worthwhile to have the youngest he it
wasn't just heavyweight champ you gotta
remember he was the youngest heavyweight
champ ever
and to have that it was okay to die now
and how's
loyalty someone named Teddy atler is
gonna get in the way of that that's a
title wave that they ain't no wall
that's been made high enough to stop
that tital wave and now I'll stop
myself yeah there
ish but but it would have to be awful
big one and you know what who we just
say that we could ever Build That Wall
that big who is any of who am I just say
do you think if you were to put yourself
in the shoes of C custom
a can you see yourself having the big
enough wall where you would choose
loyalty now if I answer the way I feel I
then then I'm you know I'm making myself
John Wayne again you don't have to
answer then I think loyalty loyalty is
important no matter what a man says what
he does in the end that he intends to do
do all along I didn't make that up
custard and and when when this all went
down those words came freaking echoing
into my freaking ears I didn't want them
cotton doesn't
help and they freaking kept coming into
my ears and what do you think still a
immature kid at the time you know I was
young still an immature kid at the time
what the freak do you think my response
was you were full
of yeah and but I got past
that